so the nerds are you doing hey look
there's people already here hi
IAB my name is markiplier you probably
knew that already but I'm sick so I just
got back from Austin I was visiting some
people at roosterteeth for reasons
unknown that shall remain secret until
the time at which they need to be
revealed
alright I'll say it I'm selling my
channel respected I'm not selling my
channel I am sick so when I get back
from Austin I supposed to record a bunch
and do meetings and whatnot but I'm sick
worst of all my mom's disappointed in me
because I didn't study Korean this
morning and so that's no good so I'm
telling you this because we have this
unspoken dialogue between us you and I
but now I'm speaking about it so I guess
I ruined the unspoken quality about it
yeah that's that's about it um I I know
I was sick everyone thinks I was sick
just like last week but I was two months
ago I don't know what it is with me I
stopped running regularly and you know
when I was well I was like running every
day and I'm not a runner but I was like
running every day and I was so healthy I
was getting outside I was getting Sun I
was getting like a fresh air I was
running enjoying you know like sniff the
sniffing deeply in in like the plants I
would like shove flowers in my face and
I were just Norv as hard as I could and
be like man this is this is living right
here this is living living fresh you
know and then I stopped doing that I
don't know why and then I didn't get son
anymore I think that's it like I haven't
seen
son in so long and which is ridiculous
because the Sun is like right there it's
fried hot there and I don't go out there
and I get said that I wonder why and
then I wonder why I get sick is because
I like I don't go outside cuz I think
humans are like supposed to get Sun I'm
pretty sure humans are like supposed to
get Sun anyway I don't feel too good I
go like some horrible thing going on in
the back of my throat I think I got a
bit of a fever but I'm fine
so no one worried about me but everybody
worried about me like I just love the
pity people need to tweet me pictures of
soup their favorite soup or their least
favorite soup as long as it's good for
recovering from some kind of illness
people need to send me just videos
saying I hope people when they see this
they number one smash that like button
that is like a mandatory if people
aren't smashing that like button like
I'm sick like if you don't if you don't
I'm gonna go straight to the hospital
and it'll be your fault number one first
and foremost the number two I hope then
when people see this they they tweet me
videos of them weeping like just sobbing
in uncontrollable fashion just like just
woohoo just like tears streaming down
their face at just the thought of me
being sick the thought of me feeling bad
in just that oh does the tiniest way
just sends people into an uncontrollable
like cry tsunami that's just a tsunami
of tears and just sadness and I want
them to tweet videos of me expressing
this sadness and whatever way they can
because I deserve it honestly if I if
I'm
that's all what I mean
listen I I just look up and I see a
comment and said that's wack yo and I
don't think anyone said that's wacky oh
and yours so though I'm real proud of
you and I'm real proud of what you've
done and I'm real proud of who you are
Thank You Luna wolf becoming a sweet
succulent member I haven't done a member
stream in like two weeks and I feel real
bad I was supposed to do one yesterday
and then my roof leak did I tell you
guys my roof leaks that happened
yesterday like it was it was what's the
opposite of serendipity what's what's a
serendipity is a good thing what's the
bad serendipity I don't know whatever
the bad serendipity is a curse a plague
on my houses a plague of locusts
whatever that means
so I went up to my I got back from
Austin and I went up to my computer room
and I sat down on a computer desk and of
course I didn't turn the lights on
before I get in there because why would
I do that I like sitting in darkness
without Sun because I'm a freak and I
said I'm a computer I put my hands on
the keyboard I'm like why is my keyboard
wet why does it feel wet cuz I thought
it was just my brain tricking me because
of course it couldn't be actually wet
cuz why would my keyboard be wet but
then like I get a drip of water on my
hand I'm like okay either there's a
monster holding onto the ceiling above
me and that's it's drool and I'm about
to die or something or there's a glitch
in the matrix at Legg so so horrible the
Sun the Sun no the ceiling and the
ceiling is leaking and so yeah and the
ceiling was leaky and I couldn't see
where and so I have foam on my ceiling
for acoustic reasons and it was all
soaked through there drips coming down
oh I don't know how to deal with this
because I just made fun of Wade for his
house leaking that's gonna happen to me
thankfully it wasn't as bad as Wade's
house Wade's house like exploded with
water but mine shall like I I so I got I
got a cup to catch the water as it was
dripping now I'm wearing my chica shirt
by the way it makes me feel good today
I need that to feel good and then once I
say so the water was dripping down right
like nowhere else but right over my
computer desk and right on my keyboard I
think I'm cursed I don't think there's
another human alive that has more liquid
accumulated in his keyboard than I do
like I'm cursed to perpetually spill
genomic you were every single second of
every single day I haven't learned by
last year's - you - I have not learned
my lesson about keyboard liquid
placement and this is my curse so my
roof is still leaking no one's come over
to fix it yet because it stopped raining
there's been a lot of rain in LA which
is weird and then yeah anyway what was I
saying
so life
oh yeah the member stream cessful no
point of this so I was good enough to do
it so I got a new computer desk I just
said of my my computer for it and then I
was like a [ __ ]
the ceilings raining and then my throat
hurt how's it going I'm not getting sick
as I was like I'll just give it a rest
I'll go rest and then I'll be fine
and then when you know it boom bang I'm
sick so yes my story did you like it a
story did you like it get more water
from the ceiling I wonder I tweeted out
like this morning
Oh sick very sick and then I tweeted it
up maybe I shouldn't have drank that
ceiling water you know I never know if
people actually believe me when I say
[ __ ] like cuz I wonder I really wonder
if people are either gullible or just
willing to believe that I'm that stupid
I don't know which one it is if it's
just like I don't know people think I'm
that dumb but I swear I'm not like I
could have been an engineer I was
getting good grades in school I was
doing great and then I just needed to do
a poll I think as a follow-up to see if
people think and I'm that dumb and the
graphics of this game are the best you
could see all my pores yeah um yeah so
I'm sick that I've been doing this dream
longer than I thought I would but I'm a
little sick but I'm fine don't worry
about me I have I have a video that I
can put up today I also got like a bunch
of we've been trying to record a bunch
of marklar makes just to like have for
future like so I could make sure I have
them out every week so that's been good
I probably edit some of the day I I need
to do something productive I've not been
productive lately so I'm gonna try to be
more productive I mean I've been
productive but just not in like regular
video stuff I've been productive oh my
god I've been writing so much I've been
ready so much and I still have to write
a little bit before tomorrow so I
thought you'd write that I gotta write a
bit I gotta add it a bit I got a bunch
of stuff to do but listen guys listen
this is very important listen to me
listen closely to my words you need to
listen if you were looking away you need
to look in my eyes look in my eyes
I am sick but I'll be okay and remember
to tweet any pictures of soup we're
gonna smash that subscribe button we're
ready to flagyl that like button and
ring that bell ring that bell ring that
bell and then hopefully sometime this
week this weekend I'll do a member
stream for those lovely sweet beautiful
members out there of which who you all
know who you are and then every other
other one of you guys these subscribers
you delicious sweet baby subscribers you
take care of yourselves I'm gonna leave
I forgot I can do effects I forget I
could do effect something I could do
effects on the stream I always forget
about that one see it doesn't look like
I'm so sick look it's a dance party it's
beautiful it's wonderful oh did I tell
you I never did a video after the live
stream last weekend um we we raised
$500,000 in less than 24 hours and the
video archive of the stream was too long
so it couldn't be uploaded but we raised
half a million dollars in 24 I didn't
even make a vlog about that I don't make
vlogs and in one of these days I'm gonna
do that I can't get back on that I gotta
get back on that I got to do that more
cuz like I used to just make make vlogs
just casually just to make them cuz you
know I keep you informed and I think but
I was so busy with all this [ __ ] and
there's so many super-secret projects
it's like I think I can't talk about
these things I've been working on cuz
they glowed I do turn on a vlog and just
say oh I can't talk about X Y Z I think
there's such cool projects but I just
haven't been able to do them here I'll
talk about them but a little bit soon
it's it's really getting down to the
wire it's really getting down to the
soon it'll be soon
so I'll get there and I promise you I
promise you you'll you'll know more
about something or other I don't know do
I have a point to this
no I don't so whoa all right anyway so
imma go imma go I'm a rest up you guys
take care remember your beautiful shiny
butterflies it is see a filth that is
YouTube so stay awesome I love you I
hope you feel better soon and good bye
take care I love you bye
where's the X Oh get out of this there's
no end button anymore
I'm not lying there's no end button hand
am I crazy there's no this is no stop
button just I guess I'm just just stream
through what that is there's a stream of
members of the job of the stream I
couldn't see this was it